Transcriber: Mahmoud Abd Elghany
المدقّق: Mennatullah Mustafa
السلام عليكم.
كيف حالكم؟
اسمى كريم ياسر، في السنة الرابعة
بكلية الصيدلة، عمري 21 عامًا.
أعمل بأكبر منظمه طلابية لطلبة كلية
الصيدله تدعى: EPSF أو الاتحاد المصري
لطلاب كلية الصيدلة.
ويوجد بها أقسام تدريب، ولي الشرف
بأني أحدٌ من أولئك المدربين.
عملنا في هذا القسم هو تطوير الطلاب، لذا
يتوجب علينا دراسة الطلاب وسلوكياتهم.
مما طور لدي هواية دراسة سلوك الناس،
ومشاهدة تصرفاتهم في مواقف معينة.
في مواقف الضغط، والنجاح، والفشل،
وكيف يتصرفون حينها.
وهذا هو موضوع اليوم.
لكن قبل هذا أحمد الله أني أملك أبوين
خارقين، دائماً كانا سنداً لي،
يشجعاني على القيام بأشياء مختلفة،
وأن أكون شخصًا ذا قيمة في الحياة.
كي لا أعيش حياة الصيدلي العادي،
الذي يعمل بصيدلية، يمتلك صيدلية،
ليتزوج من صيدلانية، لتساعده في العمل
في الصيدلية، لينجب طفلاً ليجعله صيدلانياً.
مشكلتي مع هذه النظريه شيئاً واحداً،
أنها نظرية اقتصادية بحتة.
بدأت القصة عام 2012،
حين كنت في الثانوية العامة،
كنت جالسأً أشاهد التلفاز صباحاً،
وكان هناك خبراً عن طفل
يدعي عمرو محمد، فاز في مسابقة
"Youtube Science Lab"،
وسيسافر إلى الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية ليكمل دراسته هناك.
لم أفهم أي شيء، كيف لهذا الشخص الذي بنفس
عمري أن يغير حياته بشيء يحبه.
لكن السؤال لم يكن كيف فعل ذلك،
بل كان كيف يمكنني أن أفعل ذلك.
لم أمتلك وقتاً للتفكير، لكن ظلّ
هذا الموضوع عالقاً في ذهني.
كان هناك أشخاص بالعائلة عندما أجلس
معهم أشعر بأن طريقة تفكريهم مختلفة،
طريقه تناولهم للمواضيع مختلفة،
وحلولهم دائماً مبتكرة،
ووجدت هذا الموضوع في الكلية أيضاً،
لم أفهم ما هو المميز بهم؟
لكني أتخذت قراراً بأن هذا هو
المجتمع الذي أرغب بالتواجد به.
وأكثر ما كان يميزهم هو
عقليتهم، وطريقة تفكيرهم،
وبعد فترة من الاختلاط بهم وجدت أن
هناك 7 صفات يبتعدون عنها تماماً.
مما دعاني لتقسيم الناس لثلاث أنواع: نوع
تكون حياته ذات قيمة - يملك قصة تُحكى -
ونوعاً ثانٍ لا يملك قيمة لحياته.
أما الصفات السبع: فأولها
هي القيادة الخاطئة،
وهي في نظري شحن الأهالي لأولادهم.
دائماً يجب أن يكون الأول في فصلك، ليس
لأنك ذكي، بل لأنك بني.
يجب أن تكون أفضل الناس هنداماً، حتى يقول
الناس بأنك أحسن الناس هنداماً، ليس لأن
تكون شخصاً جيداً.
كنت أمارس الرياضة منذ صغري، وكانت أكثر
رياضه داومت عليها كانت ألعاب القوى لمدة
8 سنوات، وكنت قد أحرزت عدة بطولات وبدأت
أجني المال من تلك الرياضة،
وكانت الأدوار التمهيدية لبطولة المدرسة
سهله للغايه، ففزت ببطولة المحافظه لعامين
على التوالي، فكرمتني المدرسه في الصف الأول
الثانوى، وكنت أول من يتم تكريمهم من فصلي
وقام مدرس من شؤون الطلبه بإعلامي بأن غداً
هو يوم التكريم لذا يجب أن أهتم بمظهري،
وهذا ما حدث، وتم تكريمي بالفعل، وكنت
أُظهِر بأني بطلاً أوليمبياً علي الرغم من
سهولة المسابقة.
حينما عدت إلي الفصل، قام كل زملائي الذين
كانوا يرون بأن الرياضة شيئاً سيئاً
بتهنئتي، عدا أحدهم الذي قال لي شيئاً
غريباً لم أفهمه حينها
فقال "أنت كُرمت رياضياً، لكن بعد عامين سوف
أُكرم دراسياً، والدراسة حينها أهم من الرياضه"،
لم أفهم حينها ما قيل، ولم أستطع الرد.
لكن بعد وقت، أدركت أن والديه كانا يحفزانه
أنه يجب أن يتم تكريمك، ولا أحد سواك.
كم الشحن الذي يبث للأولاد الصغار يخلق
لديهم الحقد نتيجه التنافس، حتى البسيط منه
ثانياً: الإشفاق على النفس،
شيء عادي أن تمر بمواقف صعبة، لكننا
نمضي قدماً،
لكن ما ليس عادياً، أن يتحول الأمر لمتابعة
تقدم الناس، والمقارنة بينك وبين الآخرين،
والتذمر من عدم المضي قدماً.
ومع الوقت أصبحت أنظر للناس ولا أنظر لنفسي.
مما تسبب بوجود الغيره، وفي أي منافسه سيشعر
بالظلم من عدم تكافؤ الفرص،
سينظر لنفسه دائماً علي أنه ضحية المجتمع،
وأنه خلق ليهزم.
لكن الأمر هو أن تتعامل مع لحظات السقوط،
وأن تتمكن من المضي قدماً.
ثالثاً: المقارنه،
الثانوبه العامه هي سنة المقارنه التاريخيه،
أنظر لابن عمك، ابنة خالتك، جارنا...
وكما أقول أن الله رزقني بأبوين خارقين،
لكن الطبع يغلب التطبع،
ففي مرحلة الثانويه عاد أهلي للمقارنه.
عائلتي كلها أطباء ومهندسون، وفي الصف
الثاني الثانوي، في مادة الكيمياء تحصلت علي
درجات قليله، مما جعلني ألتحق بكلية الصيدله
حينما تحصلت على 90%،
كان الحزن يعم أرجاء البيت، والكل كان
صامتاً، لا أحد يفهم أي شيء،
ومع الوقت شعرت بأني وصمة عار في العائله،
حتي إن لم يُقال لكني كنت أشعر بهذا.
وفي الصف الثالث الثانوي
كانت الامتحانات صعبه،
لكن أمي قالت لي أثناء الامتحانات، أنه مهما
كانت النتيجه فإنهم لن يشعروا بأي حزن،
لأنهم شعروا بأنني سهرت الليالي وبذلت قصارى
جهدي، وأنهم فخورون بي أياً كانت النتيجه
وأيضاً الصبر، ليس فقط الصبر أو عدم الصبر،
أحياناً نشعر بأن تعبنا شيئاً كبيراً على
أشياء نحبها كثيراً.
أعني أنه مثلاً لو أني أمارس رياضة ما وأقوم
بالتدرب لمدة خمس ساعات يومياً،
واتخذت قراراً بأني قبل البطوله سأتدرب
لساعتين ونصف مدعياً بأنهم لن يشكلا فرقًا،
وخسرت البطوله، علي الرغم من أن هذه البطوله
كانت لتغير حياتي.
هل تلك الساعتان والنصف كانتا لتشكل فرقًا؟
ربما!
أم العكس؟ ربما!
لكن حينما أكون قد قمت بعمل كل شئ أستطيعه،
ثم لا أحقق ما أريد شيئاً مختلفاً عن ألا
أقوم بكل شيء أستطيع فعله ثم لا أحقق
ما أريد،
لو أني تدربت ثم خسرت فلا مشكله،
لكن إن لم أفعل كل ما بوسعي سأظل ألوم نفسي،
وأضع افتراضات كثيره.
فإما أن تفعل كل ما تستطيع أو لا تحاول من
البدايه.
رابعاً: العدوى،
في الصيدله ندرس أنه ليس كل الأمراض معديه،
وهناك أمراض تنتقل عدواها سريعاً والعكس.
لكني أؤمن تماماً أن كل الصفات معديه،
لذا إذا أردت اكتساب صفة ما فلتختلط بأولئك
الذين يملكونها.
في السنه الثانيه لي في الكليه، كانت عندي
مشكله وكنت أعلم ما هو الحل لكني لم أمتلك
الشجاعه، كنت أرغب من أصدقائي
دفعه تجاه الحل،
اتجهت لبعض الأصدقاء القدامى، وكنا نتسكع
سوياً لشهور،
وكنت سعيدًا معهم لكن حينما أتركهم أشعر
بالحزن مرة أخري لأن مشكلتي لم تحل بعد.
وفي يوم سألتني أمي عن ماذا نتحدث أنا
وأصدقائي، وقالت أنها تشعر بأني شخصيتي ضعفت
ثم قالت لي لو أن أصدقائك لا يدفعونك للأمام
ابتعد عنهم، لكني لم أقتنع ودافعت عنهم،
لكنهم بالفعل لم يساعدوني وآخرون هم من
ساعدوني، وعندما عدت لأصدقائي أُخبرهم بأني
حللت المشكله، قالوا لي "أنت تهوى المتاعب".
ومن هنا فهمت، إذا كان أصدقائك لا يدفعونك
للأمام فأنت بحاجه لآخرين.
نحن لسنا بحاجه لمن يخبرنا أننا علي حق،
نحن بحاجه لمن يقف إلي جانبنا حينما نخطئ.
(تصفيق)
ومن هنا ننتقل لمبدأ أذكى شخص بالغرفة،
فإذا شعرت بأنك أذكى ممن حولك، فإما أن تشعر
بالغرور أو أن تضع نفسك في مجتمع أعلى وهذا
أفضل، وهذا هو المفيد لك.
سادساً: الحظ،
دائماً يقال عن الناجحين بأنهم محظوظون،
لكني قرأت في كتاب أن أولئك الناس عانوا
كثيراً لأجل هذا الحظ، هم دائمًا
على استعداد، هم تعلموا كثيراً
كلاعبي الكره الذين يحرزون أهدافاً بنهاية
المباره لياقتهم أعلى، فهم تدربوا أكثر.
حينما سُئل أبو تريكه عن بطوله أمم إفريقيا
2006، وأنها كانت فقط عن طريق الحظ،
رد قائلاً الحظ كان موجود لكننا أيضاً
تدربنا كثيراً، وكان موجود حينما حرمنا
أنفسنا من أشياء لأجل الفوز بتلك البطوله.
إذاً فالحظ شيء أساسي لكنه يأتي في المرتبه
الثانيه بعد التعب.
سابعاً: الغرور،
في النشاطات الطلابيه التي شاركت بها، شاركت
في الانتخابات، وقمت بالاستعداد بشكل ممتاز
ولكني خسرت، كم كنت مصدوماً حينها!
وكان لي صديق قد خسر مثلي وهو في نفس
عمري، لكني دائماً كنت أعجب بتفكيره،
قال لي "هناك شيئاً لم نضعه بالاعتبار وهو
أننا انتظرنا من الناس أن يضعونا في مكانة
جيدة حتي نشعر بتلك المكانة"
-وهذا هو الغرور في رأيه-
"لا يجب أن ننتظر مكانتنا من أحد
علينا أخذها بتفكيرنا وتعبنا وشخصيتنا"
(تصفيق)
أخر نقطتين سأتحدث عنهما،
في احتفالات أكتوبر العام الماضي،
كنت أشاهد خطاب النصر للرئيس السابق
محمد أنور السادات
فقال اقتباساً رائعاً لا يُنسى
"كيف خرج الأبطال من هذا الشعب وهذه الأمه
في فترة حالكه ساد فيها الظلام ليحملوا
مشاعل النور حتي تستطيع أمتهم أن تعبر الجسر
ما بين اليأس والرجاء"
وكنت أركز كثيراً علي جملة "الجسر ما بين
اليأس والرجاء"، وكم هي عظيمه جداً!
كيف أن من يصنعون الأمجاد يمرون بفترة اليأس
من تحقق هذا الحلم وفترة الرجاء بتحققه،
لكن حتى لو لم يتحقق هذا الحلم، سيعودون
لمستوى الأشخاص العاديين الذي نعيشه جميعنا
لكن لو تحقق الحلم
سيمتلكون قصة ليحكوها لأولادهم.
(تصفبق)
كنت دائماً أفكر بالحياه بشكل غير منطقي،
كنت دائماً اظنها كالوحش النائم،
طالما أنك تسير بالاتجاه العادي
فإنه يظل نائماً،
لكن إن امتلكت حلماً فإنه يستيقظ، أما وإن
سعيت لتحققه فإنه يبدأ في قتالك،
القتال يكون بالمشاكل وعدم التوفيق.
لكني لاحظت أنه من الطبيعي أن أي شخص يود
فعل أي شيء ذا قيمه أن تحدث له أشياء غير
طبيعيه وغير منطقيه إطلاقاً، وعلينا إدراك
أن هذا طبيعي للغايه، لكي لا نُصدم،
وهي بالنسبة لي ضريبة النجاح.
كل الناس يمرون بالعقبات، لكن من يستمر؟
أخيراً كلمتي اسمها "مفك وشاكوش"،
المفك والشاكوش من الأدوات التي نستخدمها
في أي مكان لنصلح ما بحاجه للإصلاح،
لذلك نحن بحاجه لمفك وشاكوش لعقليتنا
ولشخصيتنا، وبهذا أكون أنهيت كلمتي.
(تصفيق)